bonjour nicolas vidal bonjour merci
beaucoup de nous rejoindre ce matin avec
autant d'énergie sûre sur rt france
alors on va parler des ces
manifestations contre les restrictions
sanitaires elle semble se propager
il ya même menace peut-être en france
bat bien sûr magali bien sûr c'est une
tâche d'huile qui pourrait faire des
vagues dans l'union européenne
prenez les cieux parce que la liste est
très longue pays bas danemark espagne
grèce autriche ecosse italie
un peu moins en france mais on va en
parler plus loin de nous livrer et le
liban est en effet un sujet l'adducteur
et finalement il avait aussi rappelé
vous en novembre 1 et en plusieurs pays
en août dernier le manque de milan y
avait du talent il allemagne espagne
angleterre et aujourd'hui ça a commencé
aux pays-bas dans les images diffusées
ce moment effectivement il ya beaucoup
de violence aux pays bas et il ya eu
beaucoup beaucoup de monde aussi de
revenir à mon sens on a mis un peu de
faux cul sur ces violences mais essayez
seuil avec m énormément de monde qui ont
manifesté donc ça veut dire quelque
chose
j'ai envie de dire aussi qu'il faudrait
pas que cela devienne l'union européenne
la manifestation parce qu'on en prend
tout droit le chemin et d'ailleurs je
suis allé faire ma petite revue de
presse ce matin et j'ai lu la presse
belge et et tenez vous bien la mise de
l'intérieur belge année dies verlinden
pardon a annoncé ce mercredi avoir
envoyé un courrier au bourg mer sont
donc au maire dans lesquels rappelle les
conditions à remplir pour pouvoir
organiser des manifestations c'est à
dire que la mise de l'intérieur belge
est la peur finalement de la tâche
d'huile des pays-bas voulons un peu pour
ce premier point alors une tâche d'huile
qui risque de faire des vagues
je voulais pixels là nicolas vidal en
tout cas quelles sont les raisons ces
mobilisations en europe les stylos alors
oui alors vous avez vous avez trois
sujets sains qui ce qui se superposent
qui s'agglomèrent qui s'agglutinent vous
avez déjà le ras le bol des mesures
considérées comme liberticide on a vu en
france et bien entendu mais si le cas un
peu dans tous les pays européens
j'en parle en permanence il ya aussi la
perte de légitimité la parole politique
et médical c'est extrêmement important
dans ces mêmes pays européens car la
réalité c'est que les héros des élites
européennes sont en train de faillir
absolument et puis troisième point le
point social le point économiques qui
sont les premières victimes de crises
qui sont elles mêmes ce sont les classes
moyennes
les classes pauvres qui sont exposés la
déflagration économique faillites
chômage licenciements désespérance
sociale et ce qui est extrêmement
intéressant c'est si on sort un peu de
la france on se rend compte que
finalement la fracture entre les élites
européennes et les différents peuples
elle est partout elle est massive c'est
une espèce de sédition renversé en
quelque sorte
et ce n'est pas que franco français et
ça à mon avis c'est un en ce moment
extrêmement important à retenir
vous avez fait un sujet à mon passage
regardez la marchandisation des vaccins
entre astrazeneca pfizer les profits les
bonus des accords commerciaux
comment vous les homos nommé qu'on
voulait moment donné que les peuples
européens qui sont suspendues aux
accords bruxellois il trouve une
certaine légitimité
c'est en réalité un sac tu es capharnaüm
de ce côté là donc effectivement je me
disais c'est une sédition c'est une
sédition dsit renversé au niveau
européen et c'est aussi le cas au québec
mais c'est pas le sujet la matinale
enfin ce sera le sujet peut-être une
autre matinale en tout cas le chef de
l'état français lui
on attend sa prise de parole est
évidemment en france les français qui
sont pas qu'ils sont plutôt résignés
mais pas majoritairement favorables on
avait dans le dans le sondage est-ce
qu'on a eu les françaises tiennent mieux
que les autres
alors c'est bon vin parmi ce qui tient
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui vous savez
magali c'est le seuil d'acceptabilité y
regarde ça de mauvais oeil actuellement
et mme eliane macron pas ce que vous
appelez vous emmanuel macron il avait
été surpris en mazéas mars dernier de
l'a26 lité des français de rentrer chez
eux pour le premier continent il est
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron et regarde
bien entendu les variants britannique y
regarde bien entendu l'inefficacité du
couvre feu
mais ce qu'ils regardent surtout
emmanuel macron c'est le taux finalement
de positivité de l'explosion sociale qui
risque d'arriver
et puis une confusion totale au sein de
l'elysée au sommet de l'état on ou par
diers de confinement serré mais qu'est
ce que ça veut dire on confinement serré
donc à plusieurs scénarios sur la table
on reçoit des alertes scénario un
scénario de donc tout ça ne vient pas de
légitimité finalement sur ce truc et
puis il faut le dire aussi
le deuxième continent est un échec très
sincèrement on n'en parle pas beaucoup
mais ça a été un échec absolu parce que
on n'a pas pu faire respecter ce fameux
confinement attestation sortie et
d'ailleurs je
hier encore on fera du figaro dans le
cénacle emmanuel macron quelqu'un qu'un
ministre ou plutôt un proche de manuel
m'apprendre déclaré si on demande aux
français de rester chez eux et qu'ils
sortent on sera un peu désarmée
vous voyez un peu la situation emmanuel
macron je crois qu'aujourd'hui il est
très embêté il s'est énervé quand jd
suite à la longue de confinement d'une
prise de parole mercredi à dompierre et
il est complètement pris d'en face à un
mur et manuellement mais à nicolet ce
qu'elle est les français seraient plus
responsables que certains de leurs
voisins européens
alors vous avez vu ce sondage qui sur
les réseaux sociaux fait du moins ce
hashtag je vais parler avec un peu
dingue li 6 mhz je ne me confierait pas
donc là il ya une vague de fond qui
prend de l'ampleur
très certainement vous avez vu mais
entendu on l'a tous vu le gars ce
restaurateur niçois qui a à coeur ouvert
donc ça c'est une marque de sédition de
dire au glee sens populaire d'ailleurs
civile pardon d'ailleurs tous les médias
on parle depuis trois-quatre jours
qu'est ce que vont faire les français
s'ils approchent troisième confinement
on n'est pas sûr que les français
restent enfermés c'est un vrai problème
c'est un vrai problème
il vous avez des biens furent des
manifestations disséminés ça et là mais
avait l'air et socio sanitaire ça
devient un peu un problème il ya aussi
élan ce risque des deux autopsies vont
si vite pardon je le dis en permanence
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya plus de cause
nationale il n'y a plus de légitimité à
appliquer des mesures gouvernementales
et ça c'est terrible parce que sa
fracture l'esprit de la nation sa
fracture l'esprit républicain et
aujourd'hui je lui avais déjà dit il ya
une tribalisation entre ceux qui veulent
pas ce qu'on retient de confiner il ya
la désespérance sociale et cette société
est en train de se fracturer à la
lumière à la lumière de ce compte de ce
qu'on finance ce probable compliments et
surtout à la lumière de cette crise
sanitaire ducobu de 19 qui fait émerger
énormément qui fait émerger les
fractures de la france qui sont là
depuis 20 ou 30 ans mais aujourd'hui
elles sont portées aux nues
malheureusement pour nous nicolas est ce
que vous pensez que l'arrivée enfin des
vaccins commandés en tout cas par
l'europe pourrait apaiser les choses
je renvoie le téléspectateur à ce sujet
que vous avez passé avant sur l'union
européenne c'est absolument un scandale
ce qui se passe entre les bonus je paye
plus j'ai avant tout ça c'est que c'est
absolument incroyable finder astra n'est
qu'à à 5 eca qui fait 40 bis bis av
l'union européenne tout le monde
s'énerve dont ceux rendus compte que
fignon n'avait délégué
notre souveraineté souveraineté médical
l'union européenne et que c'est le un
capharnaüm jeudi teulère en vrai
capharnaüm parce qu'aujourd'hui l'union
européenne est complètement panique face
et la livraison d'accès le problème des
doses d'un sixième dote de pfizer
on tient on se retrouve finalement c'est
l'union europe est en train d'exploser
en plein vol
on nous avait promis l'union européenne
et des états membres des amis finalement
c'est pas du tout du tout les amis on
est en train on redevient la
mondialisation sauvage c'est celui qui
paie le plus et qui payent avant qu'ils
allaient 2 point final et l'union
européenne nous ennuie en disant si vous
savez si on est dans une union en aura
des meilleurs prix la réalité que c'est
pas vrai c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on
se rend compte que 1 mois moi ni après
cette stratégie vaccinale
on est là on est dans la séquence est
compliqué pour ça et aussi le dernier
point les contrats en attente toujours
devant les contrats signés entre les
labos l'union européenne ces contrats
sont absolument à 100 eu débat public et
on aimerait un jour pouvoir les lire et
d'ailleurs certains députés aujourd'hui
demandent de pouvoir lire ces contrats
et puis en quelques mots nicolas on a
aussi appris que il n'allait plus avoir
de contrôle sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire avec la dissolution de la
mission d'information de l'assemblée
nationale sur le comique 19
et bien entendu c'est arrivé c'est
arrivé hier les députés républicaine
damien abad eric ceux qui sont montés au
créneau
amer rappelez vous aussi vous avez le pc
jupiter en les décisions sont prises au
pt jupiter avec emmanuel macron entouré
le cénacle de quelques ministres donc
rien ne sort donc et puis après il ya eu
la loi de prorogation de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire qui a été voté la
semaine prochaine semaine dernière à
redon il y avait quelques 160 députés
l'assemblée donc on peut se poser la
question
effectivement aujourd'hui c'est la fin
de cette mission d'information sur la
copie de 19 et j'ai noté une petite
douceur permettez moi de me la donnez
vous la livrer christophe castaner
castaner qui répondait au député maire
qui disait la commission denquête
émissions des fondations sont
temporaires c'est la vie parlementaire
enfin pour moi j'ai pas l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui la crise sanitaire ducobu
dinars soit tellement de temporaire elle
a tendance à durer dans le temps donc
une nouvelle fois c'était un coup de
canif est rare et un coup de cutter dans
cette démocratie dans ce nomme contrôle
par le parlement finalement de cette
gestion de la crise sanitaire et on a
l'impression que le pouvoir exécutif le
menu gouvernement a du mal à recevoir de
plus en plus les critiques en ce moment
merci beaucoup nicolas vidal pour votre
édito ce matin on retrouve avec plaisir
jeudi prochain